[Music]
alright yesterday's testimony from Bruce
or blew the lid off the deep state's
attempt to cover up their rampant
corruption now thanks to mr. or Greg
Jarrett's stellar reporting and other
important deep state investigations we
now can tell you the following first in
ex foreign spy Christopher Steele was
being paid by both the Clinton campaign
as op research for fusion GPS with
funneled money through a law firm and he
was being paid by the FBI in fact Steele
was paid 11 times by your FBI in the
lead-up to the 2016 election in other
words the Clinton campaign the DNC
Christopher Steele the FBI were all
working on one team now we also know
that Steele was fired by the FBI in
November of 2016 for lying and leaking
to the press third we know the FBI then
broke its own rules their own protocol
and continued collecting evidence from
steal using the fourth highest ranking
member of the Justice Department Bruce
or as a back-channel
and for we know Bruce or had been in
close contact with Christopher Steele
and Bruce ORS wife Nellie
oh she worked whit steel on the dirty
Russian dossier that Hillary and company
were paying for the ORS were literally
making money producing the anti-trump
dossier all while passing its contents
on to the FBI even after of course
Christopher Steele was fired and of
course officially disclosing their
blatant conflicts of interests well only
to the FBI but not where he worked at
the Department of Justice fifth Bruce or
and the FBI knew that the contents of
this dossier were unverified and by the
way based on my sources they even said
Bruce or admitted it could be never used
in a court of law
but it was used for FISA warrants they
also knew Christopher Steele was
hell-bent as we pointed out last night
on taking president Trump candidate
Trump down and Bruce or even documented
that Steele was quote desperate that
Donald Trump not get elected was
passionate about him not being President
and sixth despite Steele's obvious bias
and his lies in his dossier that was
bought and paid for
by Clinton the DNC and the FBI well the
FBI still use the information as the
basis for its Trump Russia collusion
investigation and they used it to commit
a fraud on the FISA courts in their
applications not one time but four times
and they never disclosed the true nature
of the evidence to federal judges and
who paid for it they lie to these judges
it is a crime to commit a fraud against
the court and lie to a judge it's the
kind of abuse of power corruption
frankly that goes on in banana republics
this is not supposed to happen ever in
our constitutional republic in the
United States of America and believe it
or not Bruce or although twice demoted
he's still working for the DOJ Jeff
Sessions you're in charge where are you
and today the president tweeted this out
quote how the hell is Bruce or still
employed at the Justice Department
disgraceful witch-hunt he's right
congressman Jordan of Ohio also weighed
in earlier tonight let's take a look
why did Glenn Simpson and Christopher
Steele pick Bruce or in the first place
why'd they select his wife to come work
for fusion they had a direct access
Chris Steele had direct access to the
FBI he was handing them parts of the
dossier why did they also want to run it
through Bruce or at the Justice
Department questions it seems to me to
create weight and credibility behind a
document that was completely false if
you can now go tell the press and tell
other people Oh a senior Department of
Justice official is also talking about
the dossier and also passing it on to
the FBI it gives it weight when in fact
it was completely a uncredible
unverified document and a bunch of
garbage there are some people in
Washington they get it now of course the
or steal text they now make perfect
sense remember Christopher Steele often
expressed concern to Bruce or he didn't
want to be exposed he was hoping those
firewalls held now we know it and by the
way it should rock every single American
forget your politics to their core and
meanwhile Robert Muller he couldn't care
less about the real corruption and
collusion that we just showed you and by
the way Bruce or and Christopher Steele
were trying to funnel what he knew or
lies to Robert
instead they're focused now on let's see
taxicab medallions loan applications tax
returns from years gone by and lying to
investigators and we have an update on
that it's just pathetic and tonight John
Solomon out with a breaking news report
it raises serious concerns about one
facet of Muller's witch-hunt and
according to Solomon who will join us
mother's case against one-time Trump
campaign aide George papadopolis
probably completely bogus the special
counsel has been claiming they want this
kid that spent six months in jail saying
Papadopoulos lied about the sinister
details surrounding a meeting with a
European professor that he knew they
claimed Papadopoulos was looking for
information on Hillary's hacked emails
but according to Solomon's report well
the professor that they reached out to
that also wrote them and confirmed what
he said to the FBI so Wed quote
repeatedly insisted that his contacts
with George papadopolis were innocuous
and Solomon writes quote he went out of
his way to tell the FBI there was no
talk of sinister cybersecurity
intentions intentions such as a plot to
hack Hillary Clinton's emails as we have
previously reported Papadopoulos is
considering withdrawing his guilty plea
we did reach out to Papadopoulos the FBI
the special counsel and of course we
don't get comments although i think
george papadapolis his wife is right
solomon will have a full report a
damning new report tonight all right but
first we're 69 days away from what I'm
telling you is the most important
midterm election in our lifetime look at
the side of your screen
we have long warned you what the
Democrats will do if they regain power
it is a scary picture and this is
especially true for two states one
California which has now become so
liberal it's pretty much now almost a
one-party socialist state and former San
Francisco mayor Gavin Newsom who wants
to be President one day looks so poised
to become the next governor this is a
disaster for the people of California
that pay a state income tax of thirteen
and a half percent now Newsom wins
voters are going to get a super-sized
helping of radical left-wing agenda
including of course medic
here for all and under Gavin Newsom
statewide single-payer health care
system the state they not only got to
cover the citizens of California knew
they were gonna cover the all of the
states the only three million illegal
immigrants a lot of people's health care
to pay for for free take a look
plan to get single-payer path it needs
to be pulled into the governor's office
the executive needs to lead it Obamacare
would not have happened it was just
exclusively a legislative Fiat that said
Nancy Pelosi did a magical job of
organizing it but it required the
concerted contributions in the present
United States I'm not naive about it I
did universal health care when I was
mayor fully implemented regardless of
pre-existing condition ability pay and
regardless your immigration status San
Francisco is the only universal health
care plan for all undocumented residents
in America I'm very proud of that and we
proved it can be done without bankrupt
but in the city I'd like to see that we
have my some estimates that radical plan
it could cost taxpayers get this over
400 billion dollars including tens of
millions of dollars for the sanctuary
states massive influx of illegal
immigrants it means on average each
Californian would be on the hook for at
least at least $10,000 in new taxes each
year and that's assuming the thirteen
and a half percent income tax stays
where it is and meanwhile in Florida we
now have a race between Republican
congressman Ron de Santos he'll join us
in a few minutes and the democratic
Tallahassee Mayor Andrew Gilliam Gilliam
a far left candidate was endorsed by the
socialist Bernie Sanders he's ready and
willing to implement his extreme agenda
to every corner of the great state of
Florida the Sunshine State
now his platform includes abolishing ice
supporting sanctuary cities raising the
minimum wage to 15 bucks an hour a steep
corporate tax increase may be as high as
40 percent universal health care for all
increased gun restrictions increased
funding for Planned Parenthood if you
live in Florida take note this man is
ready to raise your taxes through the
roof and literally restrict your second
Amendment rights punish small and large
businesses around every turn in pursuit
of what is now the Democratic Party this
socialist mythical utopia
sadly moderate Democrats are a thing of
the past they were driven out a long
time ago I asked Joe Lieberman this is
now the party of Nancy Pelosi and
Chuckie Schumer and Maxine Waters and
Bernie Sanders it is a far left
unapologetic Socialist Party they want
your crumbs back they want open borders
and they want most of all to impeach the
president and keep Obamacare but tonight
the only group hoping for Trump's
impeachment more than the Democrats
might actually be the corrupt destroy
Trump so-called mainstream media
yesterday we called out CNN for standing
by what is a faulty story about the 2016
Trump Tower meeting now remember the
breathless reporting from fake news CNN
it's all not true
back in July take a look we have a Cuomo
primetime exclusive tonight a plane that
goes to the truth of what the president
knew and when he knew about an event
that is central to this special counsels
Russia investigation tonight
sources with knowledge tell myself and
Carl that Michael Cohen claims that then
candidate Donald Trump knew in advance
about the June 2016 meeting in Trump
Tower in which Russians were expected to
offer his campaign dirt on Hillary
Clinton it's very very significant
because the president has denied any
foreknowledge of this event in this
meeting goes to the question of intent
to collude you've been saying for a year
that we need to follow the money follow
the lies and figure out this cover-up so
how did you do it in this case talk is
about how you got this reporting well I
talked to sources all right we now know
that a source for that report the main
source was Michael cones attorney our
old friend lanny davis who back pedaled
and reversed this story making all the
reporting that you just saw fake news at
its worst and it's just the latest what
is a long list of shady anti-trump
reporting from CNN the s whole network
the stormy stormy stormy stormy network
the impeach impeach impeachment network
the Russian Russian Russian Network and
still CNN they just remain defiant even
taking a shot at the president on
Twitter oh so much for objectivity make
no mistake they try to lecture the
president CNN does not lie really we
report the news we were reported when
people in power tell lies
CNN stands by our own reporting in our
reporters there may be many fools in
this story but Carl Bernstein is not one
of them yeah actually it is
and CNN wonders why crowds of Americans
have singled them out
CNN sucks they say it they chant it they
scream it and the network still can't
even admit when they get something wrong
and by the way think about well they
think this about the network
[Applause]
I had all night I can play all the
different montages but we've got other
news to cover today but despite CNN's
long history of abusively biased flawed
reporting the 2016 Trump Tower story was
literally cheerfully picked up
repackaged by every news network back in
July except most of them at least
admitted they were wrong according to
News Buster's while ABC CBS NBC they
spent 39 minutes hyping that CNN story
as of last night they completely ignored
the Lanny Davis reversal on air and
while fake news CNN and others almost
exclusively push aggressive anti Trump
coverage we're going to show you the
full picture which includes an economy
that is literally breaking records
remember they were the Clinton news
network
they loved Obama they hated Bush now
they really hate Trump so today we
learned that the second quarter GDP
growth which we were really happy about
well it actually was revised upward to
4.2 percent and we can now report that
American job satisfaction is now ranking
the highest it has been since 2005 and
two that yesterday's consumer confidence
number currently at an 18-year high plus
more jobs than people that are on
unemployment a record-setting stock
market historic level low levels of
unemployment in 14 states African
Americans Hispanic Americans Asian
Americans women in the workplace youth
unemployment 51 year low and so much
more thankfully because the Forgotten
men and women in this country they
deserve it the American economy is
booming that's what our upcoming
elections in 69 days need to be about
that's what the media should be
reporting and the state of our country
by the way is strong and the president
has literally changed things around
we're now heading in a much better
direction